welcome back to las vegas now we already
know how the pandemic has affected our
travel plans this year
there still might be hope on how to plan
a safe winter vacation
while still being coveted safe mercedes
spoke with the travel expert on the
subject check this out
this is the time of year that most
people start their holiday travels to
see friends and family but
it's 20 20 and things look a lot
different this year travel expert janine
tornatore
is here to tell us what we can expect to
see
this year janine the holiday travel
season typically pretty busy
but this year with the pandemic on the
rise again what are we going to see for
2020 travel
it's a little hard to know what to
expect this year right so i think that
everyone is kind of trying to plan out
as much in advance as they can
which is what you really do need to do
this year we are expecting a lot of last
minute travel as people kind of wait and
see what's going to happen but really
you can plan out a little bit farther in
advance knowing that many of the
suppliers from
airlines to hotels are still offering
very flexible
change and cancellation policies so i
think that is giving people a little bit
of peace of mind if they do want to look
ahead and plan something
that's really good to know now if people
do decide they want to travel
what should they anticipate on the road
at the airports how
should we prepare for that well i think
in general over this holiday season you
can expect roads to be a bit busy people
are still
many of them opting for that
self-contained experience of
hopping in the car and taking a road
trip to somewhere they can drive
however as we've seen so far during this
holiday season the airports can be busy
during those peak times now
what people can expect to see or you
know some crowds over those
really peak travel days during the
holiday season but you can also
expect a very touchless experience um
from the time that you're going through
tsa to getting on the airport so really
if you are headed to the airports at all
this winter
you want to try to keep yourself as
self-contained as possible
bring those things that you're going to
need your snacks whatever you're going
to want to have so you don't have to
worry about purchasing those
or you know you know doing things where
you're touching other things when you're
in
the airport or on the airplane and it
sounds like some of the destinations are
doing things
to keep travelers safe so you don't have
to touch too
what are they doing they are so across
the board really it's all about safety
this season even in these destinations
a couple of examples if you're looking
for that winter break that ski
getaway places like breckenridge are
really focused on safety both in town
and on the mountain
they have mass mandated areas in their
downtown both indoors and outdoors
when you're heading up to get on the ski
lift you're going to be expected to wear
masks in the lift line and on the lift
one thing i love that they've done this
year they've actually before the season
started they expanded their terrain for
things like
snowshoeing and fat tire biking and
they've added sledding hills so that
people can do those things they
traditionally want to do and still more
easily social distance
now i know a lot of people this time of
year want to get away to somewhere warm
so i also want to take you somewhere
warm
scottsdale arizona now i've been telling
a lot of people this year instead of
hitting the busy beaches
this is the time of year to think like a
contrarian and head to places that are
in their off season so places like
scottsdale this is actually what they
call their secret season because
even on a typical year their occupancy
rates are down so
not only will you have less people at
hotels but you will have you know more
room to spread out and they have so many
great
outdoor things to do like from golf
we're seeing here mountain biking hiking
you name it all these great outdoor
things to do and what people really are
we're seeing still looking for
are those wide open spaces where they
can do those outdoor activities
social distancing at its finest thank
you so much for the great tips janine
and if you need more information
just go to our website 8newsnow.com or
you can find all of that information on
our social media